In a previous unit, you covered
supervised learning, which was a way of
teaching a system to understand
some concept based on some labeled,
incoming data.
But what about if
the data wasn't labeled?
So we use the example of teaching
a system to recognize my face.
But that involved having a bunch of
pictures that a person had already
gone through and said,
these are pictures of David, and
these are pictures of other people.
What if we didn't have that?
What if we wanted to just teach the
system that understands similar faces
without going through and
actually coding which ones were
the same person in advance?
That's where unsupervised
learning comes in.
Unsupervised learning is helping
a system learn a concept based on
the unlabeled data, so
it just learns the ideas just based
on the data that's already there.
This is very useful in
other domains as well.
In healthcare, for example,
supervised learning can be
used to help a system identify
which patients are at risk for
a certain disease early if we
already know what the disease is.
But unsupervised learning could actually
help us uncover diseases that we didn't
even know existed,
based on patterns of common symptoms.
So in unsupervised learning, we're
really going to learn about how systems
can learn new and interesting things,
based on unlabeled, incoming data.